the pits the exciting conclusion to play
date yeah this episode jake travels to
actually what was that world that whole
glass mirror world or whatever did it
have a name actually I was busy running
around doing something else and they
completely forgot if it had a name or
not so they might have said but as some
some weird glass mirror world uh which
is pretty cool you know things are
breaking the shards and they have like
the the frames of the camera constantly
cracked to it that's kind of clever
um and this demon throws Jake's still
think it's Joshua into this pit sucks
away his blood is trying to annoy him
you know and get revenge but it's not
working very well could Jake Jake yeah
and so he goes and get this other woman
named Samantha voiced by Marina service
which I pointed out good for me oh he
did um Andi and apparently her voice is
very okay I met this woman in person
okay and it is just I'm just gonna tell
you right now you think it sounds good
on TV it's just her voice is fuckin
amazing it's like oh really yeah it's a
good place anyway so yeah the throws are
in she just wants to either love or
conquer or both whatever and so she
starts beating the shit out of him so
Finn is trying to figure out how to get
Jake back invites Rainicorn over goes
through these VHS ha's of their dad
talking about how he got the demon and
how he controlled it and all this
important information that's constantly
taped over by Jake either making a
rotten food he posed for forelady or
these really dumb little movies
signature yeah he signature too which I
really want to see heat signature tear
actually because I love that little if I
saw you know of BMO sacrificing the
lives of her summary men to save the
world and trying to get forgiveness from
the word priest Shelby Shelby who of
course could just say Jack
so but they finally get some information
they travel there they they defeat the
demon by having a sword made out of
blessed grape juice blessed again by
Shelby going in shit please they they
get Jake out they go back to the real
world they bring Samantha with him and
yeah she just walks away and he has to
explain how yeah there's that there was
really nothing and Finn apparently still
lost Lane princess - yeah yeah oh and
the doors left open and the leaf Scrolls
by um I wasn't sure if that was like
foreshadowing something or if it's just
completely random um so I don't know I
remember after it happened I saw said
dude we did a leaf pop in for anything
cuz I was very there's always like a
snail or like a piece of candy or
something that's really evil so I was
like was there an evil leaf I was trying
to remember but I I don't think there
was so um yeah anyway it's uh yeah no it
was fun I liked I would have liked a
little bit more of that glass Kingdom
cuz I liked even though I guess they
kind of did it when they went in when
lumpy Space Princess was like like all
the mirrors and stuff like that but I
liked all the glass breaking apart I
like how they traveled there I like how
let me said the magic words everything
broke apart and I like that stuff I
thought that was really creative um if
the demons very funny do we know who
voiced him no he was funny whoever he
was um
so oh you killed no it's dead oh well
okay my daughter killed let me check
with this okay you can go on
Gunther tell me who voice the demon
right really I did not know that I did
like actually by the way which I forgot
about during playdate where Ice King
actually brought that up
oh good sir says this one wait what's
with that like what's a fact
oh sorry I can't do the voice this is me
me pants so yeah no it was a fun episode
it wasn't like
a huge you know epic one but I don't
know if I need a huge epic one I don't
know if it demanded that you know just a
nice resolution a little bit of fighting
and comedy and that's pretty much what
we got and yeah but the demon was funny
I like the oh oh oh that's right the
little buddy
I almost totally forgot about that no
first of it he sits on a rock then the
rock talks is all sorry I thought your
rag is like no little buddy and he gets
up and yes this really you know
colourful friendly voice it's like you
know our species sleep for the first 12
years yeah it's like yo this is my first
day waking up and then he runs into the
booby-trap demon set there's like that
said he's gone I remember I don't free I
was like also good forward to that
character oh my god
but that just makes it all the funnier
you really think this is gonna be like a
returning character he's there for
seconds so that was very funny and very
and they've done the joke like that
before like with the bubble where you
know you know there's that there's the
one words where they're wizards and
their rock gets turned to life and it's
like oh yeah but know something about
this one where you really think there's
gonna be something continuing and it
just stops you know and the bubble grant
suit was not officially dead you know at
the same time it's like they're really
building up something and they just
squash it you know and they squatches so
quickly you know just popping the bubble
or just walking into that laser booby
trap which i just love i lovely has all
the stuff you would be this just
booby-trapped it's both like really
diabolical and really pointless so no I
thought was fun I thought it was a great
fun well that's just loading up and all
that junk yada yada yada I liked it I
thought it was pretty neat I did like
his name is Kiev no that's the actor's
name that's the time okay that's a very
other like Madonna or Bjork or
Noah Nelson I don't know who
and neither do i it chances are we've
heard his voice a million times I'm sure
cuz that's how Poe's voice actors work
but yeah no I definitely maybe he was
really funny yeah it was really good um
I what done uh no I like it cuz you get
to know a bit more about Joshua and
people could argue all they want he's an
ass so Joshua yeah he's kind of just an
ass and yes he's an adventurer and all
that stuff and yadda yadda yadda but
like yeah demons a demon I get that but
what's his demon doing anything yeah
really it wasn't like he was going
around slaughtering children or anything
like that no this is just like okay I'm
gonna go to your home we don't know it
was it was copied over so maybe maybe he
was doing something bad but unlikely I
guess you know he goes to his home takes
him and chained him up into his room and
then kind of punch the guy yeah I love
when he whenever it looks like the
demons gonna kid out he's thought to
attack and they just throw his face it's
like I love it when the demons really
put that yeah is it that when that demon
plays pathetic I think that's the
funniest you know what I see with with
Joshua I see you know I character a
father character who's from a different
generation
I see so on that's like yeah why would
you hurt and torture Stephen I don't
know he's a demon it's just wait does
you know that's what we do it's you know
what good strong men do and said just
the way you talk seems you know very
funny is in 50s let's go get him we're
at metrans you see you know and it's
it's one of those things where I don't
know kids you always hear of like past
prejudices and stuff like that and a lot
of people either have like oh really
they know someone really old or they
have a relative or something where it's
like yeah love them but if they're from
a different time and it's like dammit
why did you have to grow up at a time
those look like whatever really
prejudice surprises or something cuz
it's like I like you aside from that but
damn it you're that that's stupid part
of your generation so and it's like you
always try to tell them to get better
and stuff but it's like just ingrained
or whatever so that's kind of what I see
with him I see him as like that guy who
yeah he's doing really wrong but it it
kind of feels like that's just
verdict of the time yeah I you know and
I could be totally wrong that's just
that something about the way he talks it
with the axe and he sounds like you know
like an announcer from the 40s or
something and that's just that's kind of
what people from the 40s really you know
I guess no I mean I I agree with that
but then again he's also dead so it's
not like he's continuing on doing this
so I guess I'll give you a little leeway
on that well I mean but we don't know we
don't know exactly the past you know of
this by me we know whatever the Simon
and Marci thing but good yeah well you
deserve it so that's again I could just
be making an excuse to maybe the race
it's just like no we just thought was
funny if he was a dick you know like no
other reason but that's it that's
something that uh we did discuss briefly
in the comment section about old people
cuz people are wondering why do I hate
old people and I just like old people
because they're able to get away with
whatever they want in a sense so you
kids and I hate but okay kids are kids
you have to be taught okay
by the time you're an old person a
granny or grandma or whatever you should
know better by that point that well but
then the brain starts working backwards
it's like that now you're it's like on
your way in you know your serve learning
stuff you know that's how you're dumb
but you get smarter smarter evil and
you're on your way out
you're going back to being dumb you're
going back to nothing punish kids why
can't you punish old people you know
they're gonna die anyway and that's the
ultimate punishment it's like why bother
why is that a punishment is a good thing
I I probably say you know that's why I
can't stand old people is they're able
to get away with stuff because well
they're old so we'll let them do
whatever they want they let her run and
say the n-word and it's okay because
well that's that one chef that like oh
no Paula Deen right that yeah yes you
definitely couldn't say well I wonder if
I'm humorous about that is did you ever
say it yeah I said it like once a long
time ago you're guilty well no no no
that was like I thought you were saying
something like this is the way things
should be and it was something like
black serving white oh I thought that
was like the best for us I know but I
could be completely wrong don't quote me
I didn't follow it too much like
everyone's gonna be like quoting going
again the coma Paula Deen's in like one
of my relatives I won't say which old
one it is but we're sitting there and I
was gonna go down the street to get
something and this person leaned in and
goes okay but be careful of them
coloreds and I'm like really in this day
and age you're not just saying not just
using that terminology but you're still
singing it like as in yeah watch out
those black people are gonna get yet
because you know it's the middle of the
frickin day mmm no that's my thing is
said no they should be punished and be
told no what you're saying is wrong and
stupid I I never know if it's like if
it's like a relative I'll fight a little
bit more and I'll talk a little bit more
usually cuz it's like well that's you
know my relative you know I say nothing
I don't like my relatives oh now I
really have that many that do that
really but again it's like different
times different backgrounds and
environments and stuff like that I think
that I mean it's like the phrase you
can't teach an old dog new tricks you
know it's like it's not they can't be
done I think it can be done you know I
think it's a lot of older people that
you know have learned stuff and then
come around and done great things but it
is tougher you know it's because you do
get older and slower and so on and it's
like I get that and it's sucks you know
it really sucks
um I don't know how much of an excuse it
should be I mean because you're right
you are kind of right it's like they
they are adults and they should you know
at the same time be
aware of how the world is changing and
you know and how it should be and so on
but at the same time if if the
environment has done nothing but
encourage this and then as you you stay
around people usually of your same age
getting older so you're still surrounded
by that environment and sound like these
younger people coming up to say no that
was wrong even if they're right it's
like dude like my whole freakin life has
been ruled by this rule you know so how
am I supposed to just instantly change
you know what though if these people are
still able to drive they should be in
enough - this is a different subject
there's a lot that are driving that
should not be I agree and that's what
I'm saying if you're still able to drive
you should still be able to learn that's
what I'm saying
so just take away then it's like okay
fair enough but if you're like if you're
coherent and smart enough to drive me
smart coherent enough to pick out stuff
to change with the times to learn what's
going on there's the same respect your
elders but I'm sorry I don't blindly
respect people who run around saying
what you do you yeah you shouldn't
blindly respect any way the respect
should be earned you sheikhs bag those
that burden but that's the problem most
people sit there and say oh he's lived
for 90 years you should respect this
person or whatever it's like duh it's
assumed I don't old people just like kid
I hate both of them because there's this
is that when I get old I'm gonna expect
people to hate me because when I was a
kid yeah I hate you plenty now oh that's
fine I'm okay with that hate is
something that's also earned so I don't
know how he got this tangent I mean it's
like not even any old people so much
Joshua I guess he's not a different time
period yeah a different time period
since WI whether or not the demon
torture was justified it was definitely
funny oh yeah I was like ha I've been
drinking holy water he's like I gotta go
to the bathroom so you finally breaks
free these convict splashes
oh I can't leave I gotta go pee again no
I mean with the voice you hit the nail
on think you hit the nail on the head
that he's totally from a different time
period and that's kind of what we're
supposed to get I'm guessing at least
yeah but he's a dick
so you're here Joshua was a dick what
can you do you literally cannot teach
that old dog new tricks
oh I will provide my own bottoms thank
you very much
badonkadonk sure you shake your butt I
would love to see you shake your butt
cuz clearly we're there's not enough
gifts of that I see I haven't done it in
a while I've been pretty good
III think we're due oh yeah let me make
a gif of that wait wait how do you
always have such good timing yeah okay